[Musik]
in Schweden verbrennt ein Mann seit
Wochen einen Koran nach dem anderen
geschützt von der Meinungsfreiheit
rechte Kräfte nutzen das für ihre
politische Agenda
aus die Regierung ist mehr oder weniger
gefesselt und kann die Situation nicht
optimal handhaben sie ist an eine
Vereinbarung mit fremdenfeindlichen
muslimhassern
gebunden internationale Akteure mischen
sich ein und wollen den Westen
Schwächen ih haben den das schafft
Spaltung und Polarisierung in der
schwedischen
Gesellschaft für islamistische Gruppen
bedeutet das dass es ein mögliches Ziel
für Angriffe ist das ist jetzt die
Hauptsorge muss die Meinungsfreiheit
eingeschränkt werden um die Lage wieder
in den Griff zu
kriegen die Meinungsfreiheit ist das
absolut Wichtigste im Leben von uns
allen Freitag namittag in einem Vorort
von Stockholm das Freitagsgebet in der
Imam Ali mche ist gerade zu Ende es gibt
Datteln Tee und ein bestimmendes
Thema als Grund für die
Koranverbrennungen werden schöne Worte
wie Meinungsfreiheit angegeben aber es
gibt viel bessere Möglichkeiten sich
auszudrücken als die Identität für mehr
als 1,5 Milliarden Menschen zu
verbrennen wir alle wollen
Meinungsfreiheit deshalb sind viele von
uns mit ausländischem Hintergrund nach
Schweden gekommen wir haben unsere
Länder
wir das Gefühl hatten dass sie dort
nicht gewährleistet
ist die Zerstörung heiliger Schriften
gehöre aber nicht
dazu salvan Mika sieht das anders seit
Ende Juni veranstaltet der iraka immer
wieder sogenannte Kundgebungen und er
scheint nicht damit aufhören zu wollen
la Polizei hat er bereits viele weitere
angemeldet die Schauplätze variieren
seine Aussage ist
deutlich die Botschaft ist dieode ocks
gegenüber den Anhängern des Korans
anzuwenden um die falsche Heiligkeit
dieses Buches zu enthüen gleichzeitig
soll es eine Botschaft an die
Europäische Gemeinschaft senden dass
dieses Buch nicht ihrem Gesetzen
entspricht 2018 ist salvan mumika nach
Schweden geflohen seine
Aufenthaltsgenehmigung gilt bis April
204 erlebe von tiktokpenden sagte er in
einem Interview auf der Plattform
verbreitet er seine Aktion meist htaus
Aufrufe pro Video gefilmt wird momika
von salvem einem 48jährigen Iraker mit
schwedischer Staatsbürgerschaft aber es
gehe nicht um diese zwei Einzelpersonen
sagt Islamwissenschaftler Fasel haschimi
in Schweden wird darum gestritten was
Meinungsfreiheit darf und welchen Platz
der Islam in der Gesellschaft
hat muslimische Organisationen erhalten
staatliche Zuschüsse damit sie hier
arbeiten können deshalen wie so viele
Menschen aus muslimischen Ländern in
Schweden ich würde also einen
Unterschied machen zwischen dem Staat
dem man keine Islamophobie vorwerfen
kann und der Öffentlichkeit da gibt es
Feindseligkeit gegenüber dem
Islam und Politiker die sich sehr
verächtlich über den Islam und
muslimerus damit meint er vor allem die
rechtspopulistischen Schwedendemokraten
ohne sie hat die Regierung keine
Mehrheit im Parlament sie können auch
der Grund dafür sein dass die Regierung
nur sehr zögerlich reagierte sagt
Sicherheitsexpertin ein
Ismail das ist eine rechtsextreme Partei
und die Regierung ist von ihnen
abhängig sie haben eine antiislamische
Rhetorik das haben sie auch in dieser
Krise wieder
gezeigt das sei auch der Unterschied zu
Dänemark wo die Verbrennung heiliger
Schriften nun unter Strafe gestellt
werden soll Telefonat mit dem
schwedischen Justizministerium teilt man
uns mit man beobachte die Lage und
untersuche ob Demonstrationen in
Einzelfällen verboten werden können wenn
die nationale Sicherheit gefährdet ist
mit einem Ergebnis dieser Untersuchungen
sei aber erst im Juli 2024 zu rechnen ob
Salem Nash überhaupt noch so lange in
Schweden bleiben will weiß er nicht der
IT-Experte ist mit 14 Jahren aus dem
Irak geflohen seine Kinder sind in
Schweden geboren man habe sich immer
wohlgefühlt nach dem Freitagsgebet zeigt
er mir sein zu Hause er und seine
Familie hätten sichets als Teil der
Gesellschaft
verstanden
jak natürlich gibt es Leute die
wegziehen möchten und das ist genau das
was die schwedenemokraten wollen sie
sind fremdenfeimlich und denken wir
wollen keine Einwanderer wir
schikanniieren sie wir benachteiligen
sie in der Gesellschaft dann werden sie
auswandern der 43jährige habe viele
nichtmuslimische Kontakte aber über
Politik Rede man kaum wirklich
willkommen fühlt er sich nicht
mehr ich habe große Angst Schweden war
in den letzten 200 Jahren das beste Land
der Welt aber jetzt ist es anders ich
habe nicht das Gefühl dass dieses
Schweden noch Schweden ist es ist nicht
sicher spüre wie die Islamfeindlichkeit
zunehme die islamistische
Terrororganisation alqida hat nach den
Koranverbrennungen zu Anschlägen in
Schweden aufgerufen die wnstufe wurde
auf die zweiöchste
angehoben das Bild von Schweden als ein
islamfeindliches Land hat sich bereits
etabliert und für islamistische Gruppen
bedeutet das dass es ein mögliches Ziel
für Angriffe ist das ist jetzt die
Hauptsorge
samstagmittagstalt eine weitere
Koranverbrennung mitten in der
Innenstadt von Stockholm ob man solche
Aktionen verbieten solle auf keinen Fall
sagt mir einer dieser Polizisten man
müsse Extremismus mit Demokratie
begegnen auch einen Terroranschlag hält
er für äußerst unwahrscheinlich dies sei
nach wie vor das beste Land in dem
Muslime frei leben
könnten Schweden steht zu seiner
Meinungsfreiheit und ist doch
aufgebühttimte Dingen eher durch
öffentliche Diskurs geändert werden so
auch hier das macht es so komplex wer
entscheidet was erlaubt ist und was
nicht die Meinungsfreiheit ist das
absolut Wichtigste im Leben aber warum
sollte ich eine Bibel oder ein anderes
religiöses Buch oder den Koran
verbrennen das ist einfach nicht richtig
das ist woran sie glauben und ich sollte
das
Respektieren es tut weh dass mein
heiliges Buch dass ich jedent Tag lese
verbrannt wird ein Buch das mir sehr
viel bedeutet ich weiß dass Mik
irgendeine Reaktion von von uns erwartet
seine Vorstellung von Muslimen ist dass
wir Chaos stiften und die Gesellschaft
zerstören also sei schlauer als er mach
es besser Stifte kein Chaos sondern mach
einfach weiter im
Leben ihr Appell sich nicht provozieren
lassen experten warnen währenddessen
davor salv mumika könnte von
internationalen Akteuren
instrumentalisiert
werden Putin würde großes Interesse an
momika haben
russische einflusskampagnen könnten ihn
auf bestmögliche Weise nutzen denn das
schafft Spaltung und Polarisierung in
der schwedischen
[Musik]
Gesellschaft ein Ziel das zukünftige
natoland Schweden Spalten den Beitritt
erschweren den besten
Schwächen es ist deutlich dass es
staatliche Akteure gibt die Schweden
feindlich gegen überstehen und den
natobeitritt Schwedens
ablehnen die darwiken die Situation nur
noch schlimmer wird China Russland und
Iran sind solche staatlichen Akteure sie
geben vor auf der Seite der Muslime zu
stehen und den Koran zu
schützen um diesen Einflüssen etwas
entgegenzusetzen reichten Verbote nicht
aus diejenigen die provozieren wollen
sind sehr
kreativ wenn man die Koranverbrennung
verbietet dann pinkeln oder kacken sie
eben auf den Koran oder entweihen ihn
auf andere Weise das Problem ist also
nicht die Tat selbst sondern die Art und
Weise wie sie in der öffentlichen
Debatte verteidigt
s wir sind kein Land mehr in dem es nur
wenige Muslime gibt mittlerweile sind es
etwa 800.000 und natürlich ist das eine
Herausforderung welche Art von
vielfältiger Gesellschaft wollen wir
sein deshalb denke ich dass in dieser
Diskussion auch ein gewisses positives
Potenzial steckt eine Balance zu finden
und zu diskutieren was sinnvoll und in
welcher Gesellschaft wollen wir
leben sich nicht spalten lassen
friedlich den Konflikt austragen auch
wenn es scheinbar keine schnelle Lösung
gibt vor dieser Herausforderung steht
die Gesellschaft in
Schweden